l'afer est révoltante et dans le petit
village de lépange sur vologne dans les
vosges l'indignation aviv encore l'
angoisse
un petit garçon de 4 ans et demi a été
retrouvé noyé pieds et poings liés
sa famille est poursuivi depuis des
années par la haine d'un homme d'un
corbeau qui cette fois ne s'est pas
contenté de coups de téléphone anonymes
la police mène une enquête d'autant plus
difficile que l'assassin fait peut-être
partie des 70 membres de la famille
jean-claude d'arrigo un petit garçon de
4 ans noyé pieds et poings liés une
cordelette autour du cou dans une
rivière des vosges
depuis mardi soir grégory avait disparu
quelques heures après un coup de
téléphone anonyme chez l'oncle de
l'enfant 10 de nos parents du gamin que
je me suis vengé près le fils du chef et
le corbeau précisait je les mets dans la
vologne
la vologne c'est la rivière qui coule à
proximité du village un village où on
n'ignore pas que le chef c'est le surnom
que la donnée au père de grégory jean
marie villemin
on sait aussi que jean marie villemin
était l'objet depuis deux ans de
mystérieuses menaces elle avait eu des
coups de téléphone anonymes des lettres
pareil anonyme et puis où personne je
sais pas qui a exactement qui était venu
défense et apporte la nuit des choses
comme ça quoi elle avait toujours des
menaces copie sans plus jean marie
villemin qui avait des différends
familiaux et professionnels intimement
lié à pratiquement affirmé que
l'assassin de son fils se situer parmi
les membres de sa famille mais il n'a
pour le moment livrer aucun nom
l'enquêté piétine